hello and welcome to maths implied germs
the umbrella term used for bacteria
viruses and other microorganisms are
everywhere at our home in the office
even in her car luckily about 99% of
them can't harm us but the other 1% can
be annoying uncomfortable or downright
scary
most of these pathogens are either viral
or bacterial and can cause everything
from a common cold to a potentially
life-threatening infection you may think
you know the obvious places that germs
propagate it may be the doctor's office
or your trash can
or you think maybe it's a toilet seat
but I definitely meant it when I said
that microscopic bugs are everywhere
here is a list of surprising germ hot
spots and the easy solutions to help
keep you and your family safe and
healthy number one your cell phone drop
yourself any place that's convenient
well research has found that they
carried tons of sketchy bugs in fact a
2017 study published in the Journal of
infectious diseases looked at the mobile
phones owned by teenagers and found
bacterial contamination on all of them
100 University students were selected
randomly and samples were taken from the
surface of their mobile phones these
samples were then straight on growth
Eggers and material colonies were
allowed to grow it was found that there
was 100% contamination of all the mobile
phone surfaces with a mean material
count of 9 point 9 into 10 raised to
power 7 colony forming units per
milliliter and a total of 11 bacterial
species were isolated and nowadays most
of phones are covered in leather or
vinyl cases which also provides plenty
of creases and crevices for germs to
hide the solution is simple keep it
clean first be conscious of where you
rest your personal items like restrooms
generally your best bet will be wiping
it down with a microfiber cloth I
personally use a spirit solution and
some cotton swabs to wipe down my phone
every few days and also don't forget to
clean your phone case
number two kitchen sink bacteria from
last night's dinner could end up on
today's food and utensils if you're not
careful
in fact estimates show that there are
often more than 500 thousand bacteria in
the kitchen sink that is about 1,000
times more than average toilet seat
bacteria and fungi love to grow on the
crevices in and around the kitchen sink
that means your sink can be a party for
bacteria contaminating whatever touches
it dishes utensils even your hands the
solution is to at least once a week
clean that kitchen sink with a diluted
bleach solution soap and water aren't
enough number three disturbance you know
a sponge can Harbor nasty germs but tea
stalls are just as gross a study of
hundreds of homes across the United
States found that about seven percent of
the kitchen halls were contaminated with
MRSA that is methicillin-resistant
Staphylococcus aureus the difficult to
treat staph bacteria that can cause
life-threatening skin infections these
stalls are also rated on top for
dangerous strains of E coli and other
bacteria we often use towels to wipe up
spills and then reuse them before
washing them which spreads germs
the solution is to stick to paper dolls
to clean countertops and don't use a
towel to dry washed plates wash the
tall's at least once a week in hot water
and bleach number four the computer
keyboard the bacteria that lives on our
skin fingernails hands and anywhere the
hands of beans are likely to be
transferred over to our keyboard when we
type a typical computer keyboard has
many small gaps and crevices where these
bacteria can grow comfortably 1 2018
study published in the International
Journal of environmental research and
public health states that eating above
computers is one of the causes of
bacterial contamination are the 25
keyboards that was sampled in the study
researchers found that 96% of them were
contaminated with bacteria the solution
is to simply wipe your keyboard down
with a disinfectant pipe clean it
regularly and do your best to get in
between those keys washing your hands
before and after working on a keyboard
can help to number 5 your kitchen faucet
that metallic mesh at the end of the
faucet is a total germ magnet running
water keeps a screen moist which is an
ideal condition for bacterial growth
because that water is far from sterile
if you accidentally touch the screen
with dirty fingers or food bacteria can
grow on the faucet explains
microbiologist dr. kelly riemann at the
university of arizona over time the
bacteria builds up and forms a wall of
pathogens called the biofilm that sticks
to the screen eventually that biofilm
may be even big enough to break off and
get onto your food or dishes the
solution is to keep it clean regularly
once a week
remove the metallic mesh at the end of
your faucet and soak it in diluted
bleach solution replace the mesh and let
the water run a few minutes before using
number 6 the welcome mat it serves to
create not only your guests but also all
the bugs on the bottom of your shoes in
fact one study published in the journal
anaerobe found that out of the 30 homes
which were analyzed Clostridium
difficile
a bacterium that causes diarrhea fever
and stomach pain was found more commonly
on the bottoms of shoes than toilet
seats and other bathroom surfaces this
means that the area near your front door
is one of the dirtiest in the house once
bacteria plantiffs takes in your mat
anytime you walk on it you give them a
free ride into your home spray the
doormat once a week with a fabric safe
disinfectant such as Lysol disinfectant
spray leave shoes at the door and avoid
arresting bags and grocery stores on the
mat number 7 vacuum cleaner it's all in
the bag including spreadable germs
vacuums including the brushes and bags
are like meals on wheels for bacteria
says Charles Gerba who is a PhD in
microbiology and environmental science
at the University of Arizona you suck in
all this bacteria and food creating an
atmosphere for growth and the dust they
emit sends those particles back into the
air particularly the bacteria and the
mold change your vacuum bag frequently
and do so outdoors to avoid the cloud of
bacteria that filters into the air
vacuum bags that feature antibacterial
linings are best and are available from
many major brands clean the cavity of a
bagless vacuum with diluted bleach and
let it air dry
number eight your car dashboard research
has found that this is your vehicle's
one of the most common spot for bacteria
and mold air which carries spores and
bacteria gets sucked in through the
vents it's often drawn to the dashboard
where it can deposit the spores and
germs
since the dashboard receives the most
Sun and tends to stay warm it's prime
for growth regularly swipe the inside of
your car with disinfecting wipes be more
vigilant during the allergy season as
more than 25 million Americans are
affected by asthma which is caused in
part by an allergic reaction to mold
which could be building up inside your
car number 9 soap dispensers about 25%
of the public restroom dispensers are
contaminated by fecal bacteria soap that
harbors bacteria may sound ironic but
that's exactly what research has found
most of these containers are never
cleaned so bacteria grows as the soap
scum builds up and the bottoms are
touched by dirty hands so there is a
continuous culture going on feeding
millions of bacteria be sure to wash
your hands thoroughly for 20 seconds
with plenty of soap and water and keep
your soap dispenser clean by using
spirit or bleach solution to clean it
once a month
number 10 shopping carts think about it
hundreds of people you go from guard to
cart every day while chopping with
potentially unwashed hands in fact after
sampling 85 different grocery store
shopping carts University of Arizona
researchers found that cart surfaces
harbored even more bacteria including
the e.coli and Salmonella then what is
typically found in public restaurants
the solution is to at least wipe down
the handle of a grocery cart before you
start reaching for fresh produce if you
find that your local store doesn't offer
disinfectant wipes carry your own travel
pack to keep on hand
so I hope you liked the video if you did
make sure to hit the like button below
and also make sure to watch the other
videos on our channel about how you can
keep your immunity healthy and fight off
viral infections thank you and see you
in the next one
bye bye